as someone who has in multiple horror
movie reviews said something along the
lines of jump scares stop
it stop so now there's a Five Nights at
Freddy's movie here we
[Music]
go so Five Nights at Freddy's is the big
screen adaptations also coming to
Peacock this weekend I guess you don't
even have to leave your couch though I
will say watching this in an auditorium
full of Five Nights at Freddy's fans
might actually make the experience more
enjoyable so there is that but it's the
big screen adaptation of the massively
successful Five Nights at Freddy's game
a game which Full transparency I haven't
played Five Nights at Freddy's I like
the rest of the world know enough about
Five Nights at Freddy's I know what the
gameplay mechanic is I know what the
characters look like I know enough to
make the occasional reference or joke to
Five Nights at Freddy's when the
situation calls for it but I haven't
played it all right first of all the
premise of Five Nights at Freddy's the
movie here it is Josh Hutcherson plays
Mike he's in a family legal battle for
the custody of his kid sister also his
little brother was kidnapped when he was
a kid he feels responsible for it
doesn't really play into anything for
the movie but you know it's there also
he gets the night shift working the
security room at that's right Freddy
fazbears a condemned Chuck-E-Cheeses
Family Fun Center restaurant that has
big possessed killer animatronic stuffed
animals in it but what I liked out of
the way first there was a
scene no other way to say it but there
is a scene where people break into
Freddy fazbears it's not even at night
it's in the daytime these people break
in in a very PG-13 kind of way these
animatronics dispatch the burglar it's
the best scene in the movie by far made
possible by one hit in particular it's a
pretty good one I'm not in the mindset
of a movie like this needs to be rated
are in order for it to actually be good
I mean the mindset of the movie needs to
be what the movie needs to be to make
the best film possible whatever the
rating is that's just a byproduct of
that one hit aside which was seen from
Shadows that's how they got away with it
but it was a pretty sweet hit I will say
Five Nights at Freddy's would have
benefited from being rated R if you had
a fun Gore Fest thrown in here that
would have really helped out a lot it
being Five Nights at Freddy's is tough
because one night is kind of optimal for
a game it's different but we're talking
cinematic experience it's just the
premise lends itself to someone being
there for one night I get the importance
of character development but in
execution just came across says hey good
news Five Nights at Freddy's also means
five days not at Freddy's filled with
useless [__] characters we don't
care about dream sequences that just
feel out of place and odd this mov is
about an hour 40 minutes it could have
been an hour shorter could have probably
been an hour and a half shorter I mean
it if you trim all the fat you probably
have a solid 15minute five nights at
Freddy's fan film and no my dislike for
this adaptation is not because I don't
like jump scares and horror movies
generally speaking in Five Nights at
Freddy's is jump scare fuel plot twist
it's only about one jump scare I think
they tried to have more but they just
didn't land no you don't even need that
you can have the atmosphere Ambience and
tone of the Five Nights at Freddy's game
which the game has to wind you up so
when the jump scare happens you snap
like a guitar string but the movie can
still have creepy tone it just wasn't
creepy it wasn't scary the little girl
[__] makes pillow forts correction
they were table forts they were table
forts complete with tablecloths but she
makes this fort with the Five Nights at
Freddy's killer machines there were
moments where I feel like the script was
trying to be funny is Matthew Lillard
and The Limited screen time he has that
sells my brain on that most anyone else
made me feel like I was watching stab
rather than scream I'm just left with
that feeling of who the [__] talks like
this this movie is the Cinematic
equivalent to the meal that Nicholas
Holt's character in the menu made
sprinkle in some family drama here child
trauma there some light slasher moments
some moments of killer animatronics
being nice what you have is about an
hour 40 minute slog Fest that lacks
cohesion in the end it was just a the
snoozefest absurdly predictable too I
can't stress that enough I did a little
due diligence looking into the plot of
the game before I turned on the camera
to review the movie which is to say I'm
like where are the 10 to 20 minute
YouTube videos that I can listen to
while I'm driving home from the
screening hearing YouTubers break down
the lore and story of Five Nights at
Freddy's is infinitely more interesting
than the film adaptation of Five Nights
at Freddy's Five Nights at Freddy's fans
have to suffer the tragedy we've all
suffered at the hands of Hollywood which
is they made a [__] movie out of a game
you love
we've all been there so sorry fans of
the games once again a video game
adaptation that is dog [__] now I can
see that it is quite possible even
probable there are a lot of Easter eggs
and references in this movie to the
games that I myself did not pick up on
for obvious reasons stated again don't
know for sure and I get it that could be
very fun for fans but just judging the
movie as it is uh it's about as generic
as it gets all right so Five Nights at
Freddy's the movie have you seen it what
did you think about it or of the games
what are the good ones whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see
[Music]
more